Let's go to all let's go to Dante from Florida.
We haven't heard from Don Htay for something
like five or six weeks.
Don, calls are sometimes sometimes interesting.
What do you have for me today?
Dante?
So I'll bet that a lot of criticism of Trump
and how he's handled the response to the Corona
virus.
And I think that merited a careful every step
of the way.
So, Dante, I hate to I have to talk to you.
Do you have a on speaker or Bluetooth or something?
Because your connection is not what it what
it usually is today.
No, I don't.
OK.
All right, go ahead, dantewada.
We'll keep going.
Yeah.
But there isn't really any criticism of the
Democrats and.
They're inadequate response to the of the
virus because it's the Democrats and it was
in Chuck Schumer who came out simply against
the universal basic income during the pandemic
and wanted to means test any payment.
They also came out against any recurring payment
to the people who qualified for the original
payment.
Yes.
And they've also.
They keep an eye on s..
Pelosi controls the House.
She hasn't proposed anything to deal with
the like like rent freezes or even stuff that
I would write very Chihuly in the middle of
an unprecedented pandemic, an economic crisis.
She is on vacation, cheap, cheap, that allowed
the house to go on vacation for a month to
adopt remote voting store and even progressive
like P.O.S. won't even acknowledge that the
Democrats are largely blocking the policies
that we think would be best to deal with the
crisis.
Right.
So what do you think about that?
The plans are to make you you right way.
Move.
There are no good guys.
So what do you think about the Democrats being
let off the hook for their terrible response?
Well, again, I don't know.
I don't know who is necessarily letting them
off the hook.
Let's go through each piece one by one, the
media.
I know the whole even 11.0 is easy.
Hold on a second.
The vacation thing.
I don't know that it's the best critique.
I mean, listen, everybody's distancing and
everybody is in their home districts rather
than in D.C.
And we can say it's obviously necessary to
have a remote voting system.
I'm with you there.
I don't know that.
You know, Trump.
Trump has been pushing this.
Nancy's on vacation.
It's like so's Mitch McConnell, right?
I mean, so.
So everybody's just out of there.
They're only doing pro forma sessions.
I don't know if that's the right critique.
I think the right critique, which you're you're
astutely making, is that even if a lot of
this stuff that Democrats haven't gotten behind
wouldn't have passed because Republicans wouldn't
have passed it wouldn't we like to at least
see Democrats fight for some of this stuff
if it's supposedly in line with their values.
And as you're pointing out, even AOC has bits,
you know, that the supposed standard bearer
on a lot of this stuff has been silent on
a lot of it.
So I think you're quickly figuring out why.
I have been saying for years none of these
people should be DFI.
It doesn't matter who it is, whether it's
Pelosi or Bernie or AOC or whoever.
Once you are elected, you change.
Everybody changes.
It doesn't mean that they're bad people.
It doesn't mean anything, but it means exactly
what you're pointing out, which is there's
a lot of blame to go around here for not doing
enough.
And what do you think?
Do you think that they will ever try to adopt
this policy or do you think that they're just
to go along with everything that the Republicans
propose to deal with the crisis, like they
went along with the multi-trillion dollar
corporate bailout?
That was their first priority.
Yes.
Why do you think they would ever do anything
to help the people?
Do you think that is going to keep everybody
high rise?
Listen, I am not naive enough to think that
I can tell you whether they will ever do something
if this extends.
Imagine that the current situation extends
eight months.
I think what you will see elected officials
be willing to do would be very different than
if we're able to start loosening things in
six to eight weeks.
So I don't I don't know.
I just don't know the answer to that.
I wouldn't pretend to know.
All right.
All right, Donte.
Great to hear from you.
Don Té has been calling in for a while and
it's always great to hear from him.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we
will go directly back to the phones after
this very short break.